we love you Christians just flirty with  girls and it sucks like I hate seeing it  I love you I'll sit next to you okay I  feel like she's more interested and them  than me her mine  it's just getting to me like I can't I  can't watch it I don't want to see that  you I don't know if maybe like she's  lacking like physical touch for me and  so she's going to get it from somewhere  else  but I don't think that that's fair it  has everything to do with me being  comfortable with being gay around people  I think I'm getting there I'm getting  comfortable with it but it's taking me  some time and like I feel so guilty  because I feel bad like for it taking  time and I I want to give her what she  needs but like I'm still uncomfortable  with it just like I don't want me to be  like stare like oh my god  [Music]